hi there so a lot of people have been
asking me how I make these videos and
this is of course relevant now that
everyone's work from home and all the
schools are converted into online
schools all of a sudden a lot of people
have to make these online education
happen and I think this style of video
lends itself to online education so I've
quickly go over the process of how to do
this and maybe also how to run a
university class online right so the
process is pretty simple of how I make
my videos this might not work for
everyone but it works for me
I used the Microsoft OneNote in order to
scribble on papers basically so the
thing is in OneNote you have this insert
thing here and you can print out a PDF
onto your notebook here right so the way
this looks then is you get the PDF in
your notebook and you can scribble on it
in with this using this draw tab here
you can choose a pen and scribble on it
you can highlight things and so on and I
do this while I record the screen so
that's pretty much all there is to it
you can then print out again this
notebook and you can distribute those
annotated PDF if you want now I'm pretty
sure this is here inserted as some sort
of as a an image so I don't know about
the copy/paste ability of the resulting
product but here you see this is a paper
actually made a video about and that's
basically all there is to it it's it's
OneNote it's a free free program from
Microsoft in order to do the annotating
I use in last or last last generation
Microsoft Surface tablet that I got for
cheap at some point I comes with a nice
pen and touch screen so you can
basically zoom around and zip around
while you do these things in order to
record the screen I use this eye spring
freecam software it might not be the
best but it does work for me well and
they have a cool pro edition if you need
more features but it works it really
well for recording your screen it can
record parts of your screen or the full
screen you can record with sound so I
use a microphone and then I just record
the sound from that with the same tool
and at the end you get a video file that
you can upload to YouTube easy as that
if I need to do some editing which is
rarely because I am lazy I use either
I'm Vee from Apple which comes with an
apple operating system so I have a
MacBook
that I run iMovie on I movies really
easy to edit movies on I don't know if
there's anything on Windows where it's
that easy that comes prepackaged but if
I need to do more complicated things I
use shortcut which is an open source
editor so and I believe that's available
for all the platforms and you can do
fairly complicated things with a
shortcut if you ever need to do that but
if I just need to stitch like two or
three things together I use iMovie
and that's pretty much it for making and
recording videos I believe ya well note
is that then in order to do a class from
from online not all people will just be
able to record a video and then upload
some of the things you need to do
actually live and a lot of people right
now use zoom for live basically
teleconferencing but you can also do
this sort of presenter mode where you
present and people can do question of
course you can do this via YouTube
streaming as well but then it's of
course it's a kind of public on YouTube
or link accessible with zoom I believe
you have more
control but of course zoom is a
proprietary solution and with the free
account you can only get so far so they
limit your meetings in length if you
have more than I believe three or four
people an alternative is jitsi which is
open source videoconferencing and the
cool thing here is you can actually run
your own server such that you can truly
have control over everything in order to
communicate with lots of people of
course people use slack but again slack
is a proprietary service and an
alternative to that would be rocket chat
again where you can run your own server
and it is fairly similar to slack in
order to collaborate or share just
general notes of course Google's suite
of Docs and sheets and so on is
excellent and for classes especially
piazza is a good place you can sign up
as a class you can just have have TAS
sign up as TAS and you can have your
students sign up as students and then
the students can ask questions and then
other students or the TAS can answer
those questions basically a bit of a
forum but you can also announce things
there for your classes it's pretty cool
and it's really geared towards online
classes and it's free so I know a lot of
universities are using that right now so
if you're looking for some sort of
announcement or discussion board for
your class Piazza is definitely a good
place to be and lastly we sometimes have
classes where students have to submit
projects and we we actually use CMT for
this because it's it's really neat where
you can you know set deadlines and
everything students can upload and then
you can assign reviewers to those
projects which in our case are us the
TAS and you know you can have mentor
reviews and so on
so since he's actually very good maybe a
bit of an overkill if you just run a
single class but um it has lots and lots
of features and of course the big
conferences also use CMT so it's
definitely stress tested alright so that
was it
from for my videos or at least how I
make them I just you know print out the
PDF sit down for half an hour and rant
about it and that's pretty much it and
then you throw it on YouTube or
distribute the file however you want and
with that I hope I answered a little bit
of these questions and yep I all wish
you healthy rest of the corona season
bye